good morning guys i'm little legendary
lucrezia from everyone from the wonderful
janiculum and today we will talk about what
we talk about the price today let's talk a little
about the difficulties that students
encounter when they study italian i must say
that lucrezia is a fantastic
italian teacher she has a channel on
youtube now  reference point for
all foreigners who learn Italian
how to get over thanks laren italia
lucrezia a perfect and therefore today
we speak Italian but
we will do it
walking through the beautiful streets of the
Gianicolo because we are here in this
wonderful neighborhood let's start with the
first thing you think is  problematic
for students of Italian then the
first thing that comes to mind right
off the bat are the prepositions because the
prepositions follow rules in
most cases, however, there are
many exceptions and I find that
this grammatical topic
should somehow  study at the beginning but
continue  always revising I have sometimes
met students who think they
know how to use prepositions and they
have a very high level of Italian
but they don't want to re-study
prepositions because they think that
the example of a
proposition that people get wrong is a subject for beginners  of
money is the most let's say wrong
ones are the used ones the ones that
pose the most problems are from in to even
for sometimes and therefore I want to dispel
this myth that is, prepositions
are not a beginner's topic I
do not agree faults are for they are
a  topic for any level for
any student for everyone i.e. they need to be
reviewed and I like to do this
metaphor no of learning or
studying, whatever you
want, spiral so let's go on
but then let's go back to that point no
then hosted lot I like
let's go back to that point  from another
point of view so let's study the same
thing but in more depth great
so this is  the first I too am
talking too much that it would end ok and the
second thing the second I look at what
could be the pronunciation is here
we can say many but I
will only say a few then the sound
psa beginning of the word psychological this is
a bit problematic
then the sound and  the sound is difficult
even for Italians as indeed
some say spaghetti
I don't have very often I'm not
able to pronounce deal correctly
and then the vowels we say
are sometimes skipped for example the e at the
end of the word is pronounced in
this is often the anglophones true and
vice versa also another thing with a
note that comes to mind very
often the americans say for example
john they already say they put the
exact one for example giuliani crucibles
animated giuliano exact what then
so what does this do to us  understand that the
prepositions excuse me please promise makes us
understand that in Italian
the vowels are always full up to
90 for c  ent in 90 percent of cases
because obviously then precisely we have the
iii as a function of how to say a 2 the
curly cit of the sound
therefore it simply serves as
sugar in the exact construction site it
simply serves to pronounce the g sweet
lacci sweet no then then another
another problematic topic is the
comparative sentence because in Italian
we have the choice between di and that in the
comparative sentence depending on
what comes after a base to
the grammatical function of the word yes
adverb adjective etc. and therefore
many think thinking but in
their own language they always use only  that an
example
he is taller than stefano and this
is not correct where we should say he
is taller than stefano because stefano is
a proper name so he wants to first
amazing the boy we stopped for a
moment to take a break why do the
boat interviews it was beautiful mara of
the difficult month so now we conclude
with almost we follow the one who gives
ba  mbino then I would say that
another somewhat problematic point is the periphrasis being
more gerund which in Italian indicates the
so-called present progressive so
now I am speaking and luca is
holding the video camera with these
contracts in place and he is listening to
this too because it represents a problem
because  it is often used by
imitating one's native language therefore
in the case of English speakers
this periphrasis is used to talk about the future
and this obviously is not correct
because in Italian there is a
future tense and that is always used for
any type of future action therefore
we in Italian  we don't make a distinction
between planned future uncertain
future spontaneous future things like this we only have
a verb form of future for the
real one is that
and then let's say the last point that I
noted down is the structure
everything that is a bit difficult to
understand the function  of what in this
structure and therefore I often hear everything
that everything that yes  you hear precisely in
Italian that a part of the structure is missing
all that is used together is
let's say the totality of the components of
this structure which gives meaning to the
structure itself drink it well said
I like it beautiful you want and the other one not in
reality I would have also finished this  like
I would have even finished luca I cut ok
guys thanks a lot and above all
thanks to the creation thanks to three no
sorry it's a bit precarious of the
director but that's the beauty because if
we were sitting down to do the little lesson like this you'd be terribly
bored
month instead  fun to see luca and
lucrezia who venture through the fields
of fields to the grammatical fields and
in front of the famous cannon of the janiculum
because we remind you that if i and
lucrezia we are from rome
she rome north and rome south but both are the
same transplanted to another part  by
ron other part of rome guys have a
nice day hugs and see you
soon here on youtube
bye
[Music]